every election year the news does a
story about some
animal that can predict the winner you
know what i'm talking about like some
goat in idaho
or a monkey in china that actually
happened
back in 2016. look at this his yellow
shirt apparently reads king of
prediction in chinese
and there you go looks like the king has
picked
trump that's right that monkey predicted
donald trump would win
by hugging his cutout yeah and he made
it look so
easy i mean why can't gregory do that
gregory who's gregory well gregory's my
pet turtle i've had him for 32 years
and he's never once predicted the
winning candidate
not once i'd check it out he first
picked dukakis over the first george
bush
then bush over clinton then dole over
clinton
gore carey mccain romney and hillary
i have lost thousands of dollars in bar
bets that's why i got rid of them
wait a minute andy don't you see gregory
is consistently picking the loser he's
amazing
all you have to do is bet on the
candidate he doesn't pick
you're going to win every time oh great
now you tell me
andy
and cut well that concludes our test of
the
wa sound effect great job andy
no problem conan that's right the whole
sketch was just our way of testing the
sad trombone sound effects
and i know what you're thinking why
didn't you just play the sound effect
without the sketch
because this way i got a lot of
departments involved
and i got the chance to reconnect with
staffers i haven't seen since the start
of the pandemic
writers script supervisors the graphics
department
clips and photo research the costume
department
the props department elijah our
full-time turtle wrangler
and of course the sound effects
department
oh and special thanks to the engineers
at california's jet propulsion
laboratory
for monitoring andy's election turtle
sketch via satellite
you did it again guys
so wait i didn't have to murder this
rare turtle then
you murdered a rare turtle
hey we still got it